in mexico city cars are everywhere over
3.5 million to be exact and it's not
exactly great for the environment
but fear not because there's a solution
that can change all of that and that
solution is a
volkswagen beetle
welcome to alto redemiento automotris a
mechanical workshop that specializes in
transforming old gas fueled cars into
electric cars this is
alvaro de la paz is the engineer behind
the car conversion
and then there's hector my name is
hector ruiz and i'm a computer scientist
hector is responsible for gathering the
electrical parts and making sure they
work right yeah i do the purchasing the
extensive testing of the components if
we have to burn something i'm the guy
in order to learn how to do a electric
car conversion you don't need any
specific degree it's something very
simple after reading a lot of books and
taking training courses i believe anyone
can do it
hector and alvaro learned that
converting older cars is both cost
effective and safer for the environment
[Music]
by removing all the parts related to
fuel combustion they can install the
electrical components to have a fully
functional electric car with zero
emissions
elements
[Music]
this car makes me free it's like the
nirvana of the cars you are free from
gas stations you are free from the
checkup every six months
reusability is something that the
general public has to take into account
in order to be pollution free if we want
to have a better world for our children
or grandchildren or future generations
we have to be part of this solution so i
believe the best way to start something
important for the world at large is to
do this kind of projects
[Music]
[Music]
you